[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich ihnen Fußball und mehr hat
Norbert Lehmann für sie ein schönen
guten Abend als erster Regierungschef
war der Kanzler beim neuen
brasilianischen Präsidenten zu Besuch
Deutsch brasilianischer Schulterschluss
Präsident Lula und Kanzler Scholz finden
viele Gemeinsamkeiten Militärhilfe für
die Ukraine lehnt Brasilien aber ab
wieder Massenproteste in Frankreich
hunderttausende sagen Nein zur
Rentenreform der Regierung macron
und neuer Spielzeug Trend digitale
Welten Sie virtuelle realitäterobert die
Kinder zu machen
heute ist der letzte Tag an dem die
grundsteuererklärung fristgerecht
eingereicht werden kann außer in Bayern
da wurde die Frist noch schnell bis Ende
April verlängert dennoch immer fehlen
viele der Erklärungen insgesamt müssen
nach einem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts fast 36
Millionen Grundstücke neu bewertet
werden aber bis gestern wurden erst für
gut 71% Erklärungen bei den Finanzämtern
eingereicht aus Thüringen berichtet
Florian kocik
Beratungstermin im Finanzamt Monika und
Matthias weißhahn haben ein Grundstück
bei Erfurt geerbt samt baufälligem Haus
dafür müssen sie die
grundsteuererklärung machen sind damit
aber völlig überfordert
habe ich überhaupt ein Grundstücken
Betrieb und eine Forstwirtschaft obwohl
uns das glaube ich schon ganz angeht ne
nein aber die Bürgergruppen drauf und
dann denken
welche Daten angeben muss hängt vom
Bundesland ab elf Länder folgen dem
bundesmodell fünf haben eigene Modelle
darunter Bayern der Freistaat kündigt
heute an seine Frist noch mal um drei
Monate zu verlängern wir wollen damit
noch einmal Entlastung geben für die
steuerbraten Berufe insbesondere und es
ist auch deswegen niemand negativ
betroffen jetzt schon abgegeben hat
Deutschland und die Grundsteuer ein
Flickenteppich und gegen das
bundesmodell will nun der
eigentümerverband Haus und Grund
gemeinsam mit dem Steuerzahlerbund
klagen das grundsteuermodell des Bundes
ist intransparent es ist ungerecht die
Bodenrichtwerte können gerichtlich nicht
überprüft werden und darüber hinaus
werden einzelne Eigentümergruppen
benachteiligt und darüber werden dann
Gerichte entscheiden müssen bis dahin
fordern die Verbände von den Ländern die
Grundsteuer nur vorläufig zu erheben
bislang gibt es solch einen
Vorläufigkeitsvermerk wie es ihnen
beispielsweise beim Solidaritätszuschlag
gibt bei der Grundsteuer nicht für die
Bescheide also für falsch hält dem
bleibt nur innerhalb eines Monats
Einspruch beim Finanzamt einzulegen wird
die heutige Frist übrigens nicht
eingehalten drohen Strafen bis hin zu
einer Schätzung der grundstücks- und
Immobilienwerte was laut Erfurter
Finanzamt sicherlich nicht zugunsten der
säumigen Steuerpflichtigen ausfallen
würde das wollen die Weisheits auf jeden
Fall verhindern und ihre Erklärung
schnellstmöglich einwerfen
ganzer Scholz sitzt am Abend im Flieger
zurück nach Deutschland nach seiner
Südamerika-Reise bei seinem letzten
Stopp in Brasilien ging es um die
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit aber auch
um den Ukraine Krieg da brasilianische
Präsident Lula Drang auf eine
Friedensinitiative und brachte sich und
China als Vermittler ins Gespräch der
Kanzler betonte es könne keinen Frieden
über die Köpfe der Ukraine hinweggeben
über das erste Treffen von Scholz und
Lula berichtet Klausberg
Wiedersehen mit Freude der neue frühere
Präsident Lula der Silber und der
Bundeskanzler Brasilien und Deutschland
können endlich wieder miteinander reden
ich freue mich
wir freuen uns alle das passieren zurück
auf der Weltbühne ist und sich wieder
für eine stärkere regionale Integration
in Lateinamerika einsetzt ihr habt
gefehlt lieber Lola
Lulas Reaktion ungewöhnlich mitten in
der Rede des Gastes der ihn nach der
Umarmung umwirbt es gibt viele Themen
bei denen wir eng zusammenarbeiten
wollen der Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
der Schutz des Amazonas Regenwaldes der
Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien und
windkraft und Solarenergie die
Herstellung grünen wasserstoff ist eine
sozialgerechte Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft und Fortschritte beim EU
Markus zur Abkommen Brasilien ist
reichen Rohstoffen die deutschland
braucht beide wollen die Regenwälder im
Amazonasgebiet schützen doch es hakt
auch militärische Unterstützung für die
Ukraine gegen Russlands Angriff lehnt
Luna ab
Brasilien hat den Entschluss gefasst
keine Munition zu verkaufen weil wir
nicht wünschen dass die Munition in
diesem Krieg verwendet wird
stattdessen wird Lula für Gespräche
zwischen den Kriegsparteien mögliche
Vermittler Chinas Präsident Ski und Luna
selbst
Korruption als strategische Waffe davor
warnt die Organisation Transparency
International autokratische Staaten
versuchten so ihre Interessen
durchzusetzen ein Beispiel der
Korruptions Skandal im Europaparlament
rund um ex-vizepräsidentin er war Kili
sie und andere Abgeordnete sollen
Bestechungsgelder angenommen haben
bisheriger Ermittlung gehen davon aus
dass Marokko und Kata auf diese Weise
Einfluss auf politische Entscheidungen
nehmen wollten
um mehr zum weltweiten Korruptionsindex
finden Sie in der ZDF heute App dort
können Sie sich unter anderem anschauen
welche Länder besonders gut und welche
besonders schlechter stehen und wie die
Lage in Deutschland bewertet wird
in Frankreich tobt weiter ein Streit der
aus deutscher Sicht auf den ersten Blick
vielleicht nicht so leicht
nachzuvollziehen ist es geht um die
geplante Rentenreform auch heute ging
10.000 dagegen auf die Straße die
Regierung will unter anderem das
Renteneintrittsalter schrittweise von 62
auf 64 Jahre Anheben der faktogenen
Französinnen und Franzosen derzeit mit
knapp 61 Jahren in Rente in Deutschland
sind es gut 63
beide Systeme sind aber schwer
vergleichbar Französinnen und Franzosen
steigen im Schnitt früher ins
Arbeitsleben ein zahlen höhere
Rentenbeiträge und es gibt jede Menge
Sonderregelungen für bestimmte
Berufsgruppen Thomas Walde über den
zweiten großen Protesttag gegen die
Reform
am Abend kam die größte der landesweit
mehr als 200 Demonstrationen an ihrem
Ziel in Paris an die Gewerkschaften
wolle mit dem Druck der Straße
verhindern das Franzosen länger arbeiten
müssen dass er unnötig ungerecht und
unsozial sie haben mit dem ersten
Protesttag die öffentliche Meinung
gewonnen nun wollen wir die zweite
Schlacht gewinnen und die Regierung
überzeugen die Reform zurückzuziehen
viele Metrostationen in Paris sind
geschlossen an Bahnhöfen an denen sich
sonst tausende Reisende drängeln
herrschen Lehre und Frustration
und alles war geschlossen die Opposition
von links und rechts außen trägt den
Widerstand ins Parlament tausende
Änderungsanträge sollen das Gesetz
stoppen durch den heutigen Tag sieht man
sich bestätigt
es waren heute mehr Menschen auf den
Straßen weil mehr und mehr Franzosen
gegen die Rentenreform sind
nicht nur ein gewöhnlicher Tag der
Demonstration das ist eine Art von
bürgeraufstand
auch einige Abgeordnete aus dem
Regierungslager wollen der Reform nicht
zustimmen Präsident macron bekräftigte
dagegen zuletzt gestern bei einem Besuch
in den Niederlanden die demografische
Entwicklung mache das Gesetz nötig ist
der reformelle diese Reform ist
unausweichlich auch wenn wir uns mit den
anderen Europäern vergleichen die Reform
ist nötig um das System der
Lastenteilung zu sichern
Gewerkschaften schätzen das heute mehr
Menschen demonstriert haben als beim
ersten Aktionstag Unternehmen sagen es
hätten weniger Menschen gestreikt am
Abend kam es zu Rangeleien und mehreren
Festnahmen
nach Deutschland da ist die Zahl der
Arbeitslosen zu Jahresbeginn
saisonbedingt gestiegen laut
Bundesagentur für Arbeit waren im Januar
zwei Millionen 616.000 Menschen ohne Job
das sind
162.000 mehr als im Dezember und
154.000 mehr als im Januar vergangenen
Jahres die Arbeitslosenquote steigt
damit um 0,3 Punkte auf 5,7%
. ein Arbeitsleben lang ein Betrieb treu
bleiben das ist heutzutage alles andere
als selbstverständlich erst recht wenn
der Job mag wie zurzeit Beschäftigten
viele Möglichkeiten bietet für die
Unternehmen heißt das die Angestellten
sollten so zufrieden sein dass sie gar
nicht erst auf die Suche gehen Stefan
Schlösser mit einem Beispiel
gelernte Heizungsbauer wie Alexander
krumm sind begehrt Fachkräftemangel
aller Orten er könnte leicht einen neuen
Job finden doch er fühlt sich wohl bei
seinem Arbeitgeber im vergangenen Jahr
wurde umgestellt auf eine vier Tage
Woche ich habe einen kleinen Sohn zu
Hause der freut sich natürlich auch wenn
der Papa mal einen Tag die Woche mehr zu
Hause ist und ja von der Seite läuft das
schon Super
9 statt 8 Stunden am Tag 36 statt 40 in
der Woche bei vollem Lohnausgleich die
Mitarbeiter motivierter Baustellen
können auch an einem Tag erledigt werden
das spart Fahrzeiten eine Rechnung die
aufgeht
auf der einen Seite sind wir wirklich
effizienter in vielen Bereichen auf der
anderen Seite binden wir damit aber
langfristig die Mitarbeiter und meinen
Mitarbeiter ist sind hier das wahre gut
und deswegen rechnet sich das 37 Prozent
der Beschäftigten verspüren laut einer
aktuellen Umfrage keine Bindung zu ihrem
Arbeitgeber und sind offen für einen
Jobwechsel Unternehmen müssten sich
stärker um Ihre Mitarbeiter bemühen wenn
sie sie halten wollen sagen Experten
also
Arbeitsplätze schaffen die sinnhaft sind
wo man stolz auf sein Tagwerk ist
flexible karrierefreiung spielt eine
große Rolle Investitionen in die
persönlichen Stärken des Mitarbeiters
der Aufbau funktionierender Teams ist
ganz ganz wichtig die vier Tage Woche
ist nur ein Instrument um Mitarbeiter
ans Unternehmen zu binden aber seit sie
das Arbeitszeitmodell hier bei senatec
eingeführt haben konnten sie schon zwei
neue Mitarbeiter gewinnen und alle
anderen halten
in Hessen wird am 8 Oktober ein neuer
Landtag gewählt die hessische SPD will
an diesem Freitag entscheiden mit
welcher Spitzenkandidatin sie in den
Wahlkampf zieht vieles deutet auf
bundesinnenministerin Nancy faceer hin
laut Medienberichten werde Phaser auch
im Fall einer Spitzenkandidatur erst
einmal Ministerin bleiben darauf soll
sie sich mit dem Kanzler verständigt
haben daran gibt es jedoch Kritik Türkei
wie lautet die Kritik
zu dem Kern geht es um die zu hohe
Doppelbelastung durch Innenministerium
und gleichzeitige Spitzenkandidatur
beides seien Vollzeitstellen der grüne
Fraktionsvize von Nord beispielsweise
befürchtetes käme dann zwangsläufig zu
einer Vernachlässigung einer der beiden
Aufgaben auch wenn man im Hinterkopf
haben muss es einige Kritiker Parteien
angehören die sich ebenfalls Hoffnung
auf den Gewinn der hessischen
Landtagswahl machen ist die Kritik
dennoch natürlich ernst zu nehmen denn
das Bundesinnenministerium ist mit 2000
Mitarbeitern und 19 unterstellten
Behörden keine Kleinigkeit zu machen in
diesem kriegs- und Krisenzeiten die SPD
gibt sich allerdings entspannt auch der
CDU Bundesinnenminister Kanter sei 1995
schon beides gleichzeitig gewesen für
Kanzler Scholz hätte die doppelte Phaser
gleich ein doppelten Reiz denn sollte
sie es in Hessen nicht schaffen denn in
viele für ihn eine Kabinettsumbildung
und sollte Frau Faser vielleicht auch
mit Hilfe ihrer bundespolitischen
Prominenz die Wahlen in Hessen gewinnen
dann wäre damit die Blockade macht der
Union im Bundesrat verloren was der
Ampel deutlich mehr Beinfreiheit
verschaffen würde also eine vielfach
politische Personalie danke für diese
Einschätzung theokol
die Wiederholung der Wahl in Berlin kann
wie geplant am 12 februar stattfinden
mehrere Abgeordnete Bürgerinnen und
Bürger hatten versucht das zu verhindern
per Eilantrag beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht den wiesen die
Richter jetzt zurück wegen zahlreicher
Pannen bei der Wahl im September 2021
hatte der Berliner
Verfassungsgerichtshof die Wiederholung
der Abstimmung angeordnet
US-Außenminister blinken setzt sich in
nahosta für ein die Gewalt zwischen
Israelis und Palästinensern zu beenden
in ramala im Westjordanland versicherte
er Palästinenser Präsident Abbas weiter
an der zwei staatenlösung festzuhalten
seit Jahresbeginn hat die Gewalt wieder
zugenommen israelisch starben bei
Anschlägen auf palästinensischer Seite
wurden bei israelischen Razzien mehrere
Zivilisten getötet darunter auch Kinder
Papst franziskus hat seine sechs tägige
Friedensmissionen zentral und Ostafrika
begonnen am Nachmittag landete der
Hauptstadt der Demokratischen Republik
Kongo knapp die Hälfte der 100 Millionen
Einwohner ist katholisch so viele wie in
keinem anderen Land Afrikas seit
Jahrzehnten gibt es blutige Kämpfe um
Macht und Rohstoffe
fünfeinhalb Millionen Menschen sind
Flüchtlinge im eigenen Land Susan von
Lojewski berichtet über die Lage der
Grenzregion
Goma im Ost Kongo ein flüchtlingszelt
reiht sich an das nächste zu
zigtausenden sind Menschen in die
Regionalhauptstadt geflohen wenigstens
etwas Schutz erhoffen sie sich hier
dabei gibt es seit Jahren keine
wirkliche Sicherheit mehr rund uma
wenn man genau hinsieht ist jeder und
jede von uns traumatisiert wenn Sie auf
einem Plastikbehälter schlagen dann
bekommen wir fast einen Herzinfarkt
knapp 4 Millionen Menschen haben im
Ostkongo ihr zu Hause verloren sie
fliehen vor dem Terror der m23 Miliz die
mutmaßlich vom Nachbarland Ruanda
unterstützt wird die Lebensbedingungen
der Flüchtlinge mehr als erbärmlich hat
Döner wir haben nichts zu essen wir
können nur betteln wir müssen sogar
betteln um von jemandem Salz zu bekommen
im Kampf zwischen der M 23 und den
kongolesischen Truppen geht es vor allem
um Rohstoffe und macht zwar haben beide
Seiten immer wieder einen
Waffenstillstand zugestimmt gehalten hat
der aber nie
dass der Papst nun in das Krisen
geschüttelte Land kommt soll ein Zeichen
der Hoffnung sein mehr als die Hälfte
der Bevölkerung ist katholisch
ich glaube der Papst kann sein
diplomatisches Geschick und seinen
Einfluss auf die verschiedenen Führer
nutzen um diese unsichere Situation im
Ostkongo aufzuheben das hoffe ich
im Dezember sollen in der Demokratischen
Republik Kongo Wahlen stattfinden ob es
dazu kommt experten fürchten ihr dass
der Konflikt zu einem Krieg mit dem
Nachbarland Ruanda eskaliert und sich
die flüchtlingskrise dramatisch
verschärft
zurück nach Deutschland und da lädt
Nürnberg in dieser Woche nach zwei
Jahren corona-pause wieder zur
weltgrößten Spielwarenmesse
in beiden Teilen sieht das immer noch so
aus Spiele zum anfassen aber eines
zeichnet sich inzwischen ab die digitale
Welt hält auch um Kinderzimmer Einzug
metatoys also Spielzeuge die reales und
virtuelles vermischen sind einer der
Trends Claudia Vogelmann hat sie es
angeschaut
lukas ist noch skeptisch bis er sieht
was in Kürze auf seinem Arm passiert auf
den ersten Blick ist es ein Tattoo zum
Aufkleben die zweite Perspektive
ermöglicht das Smartphone mit einer App
wird das Tattoo auf Lukas Arm animiert
hüpft wackelt im Kopf schaut runter
schaut wieder hoch auch die achtjährige
Fleur guckt noch etwas ungläubig obwohl
sie genau wie Lukas zur Zielgruppe
gehört doch Fleur weiß warum sie bei
diesem Spiel nicht mithalten kann ich
habe kein Handy deshalb kann ich auch
nicht spielen
noch entdecken Fleur und Lukas die Welt
des Spielens analog im Hier und Jetzt
auf der Spielwarenmesse doch ohne
Smartphone oder Tablet können manche
Neuheiten nicht gespielt werden
metaphirs heißt dieser Trend das
Eintauchen in eine virtuelle Welt so
kann ein schlichtes Memory Spiel zum
Hörerlebnis werden
[Musik]
also das metavers ist eine Spielwelt die
sich derzeit vor allem noch eine ältere
richtet aber immer jünger wird das heißt
wir sehen Anwendungen die es auch
Kindern ermöglichen ein reales Spielzeug
mit einer virtuellen Welt zu verknüpfen
es gibt auch erste Ansätze dass Kinder
komplett in virtuell Welten eintauchen
können auch diese Sammelkarten sind die
Eintrittskarte für spielen im
dreidimensionalen Raum das Spielen
verändert sich und wird zunehmend zu
einer Mischung von analoge und digitaler
Welt
jetzt kommen wir zum DFB-Pokal noch
weiter stehen ja die achtelfinalspieler
an ja da müssen die Bayern morgen bei
Mainz antreten der FCB nach drei
Unentschieden in Serie gar nicht in Form
da kommt diese Personalie genau zur
rechten Zeit Top-Verteidiger Jean
concealo von ManCity wird nach München
ausgeliehen der portugiesische
Nationalspieler ein Außenverteidiger mit
Drang nach vorne ist in der Champions
League schon öfter aufgefallen hier
gegen Leipzig eine sehr sehr sinnvolle
Verstärkung finde ich die wir da wie
gesagt sehr spontan noch gekriegt haben
über uns freuen kannst weil die Bayern
Abwehr gerade auf den Außenpositionen
zuletzt öfter ins Wackeln geriet wie
beim 1:1 Ausgleich der Frankfurter am
letzten Samstag
wieder hinkriegen ich werde auch ein
paar Anpassungen machen jetzt nichts
dramatisches ein bisschen was habe ich
mir auch überlegt dass wir da ein
bisschen mehr ja wie diesen diesen Fokus
kriegen Richtung Tor Fernschüsse Schiene
zuletzt das einzige Bayern Rezept je
näher ist im Tor kam desto harmlos er
wirkte der Rekordmeister beim Gegner
weiß man wie die Bayern zu bezwingen
zuletzt gab es zwei Mainzer Siege in der
Bundesliga ein 3:1 im vergangenen
Frühjahr wir kennen diese Spiele es ist
ein richtig geile Herausforderung wenn
der Bundesliga Tabellenführer das
Kampfspiel der Mainzer nicht annimmt und
verlieren sollte würde die Laune von
Trainer nagelsmann bestimmt nicht besser
werden
beim Bayern-Jäger Union dagegen ist ein
spektakulärer Wechsel in letzter Minute
geplatzt der ehemalige realen
Mittelfelds da ist gut sollte in die
Alte Försterei wechseln das wäre der
namhafteste Neuzugang in der Union
Vereinsgeschichte gewesen der fünfmalige
Champions League Sieger war heute sogar
zum Medizincheck in Berlin dann aber die
Nachricht der die kommt nun doch nicht
zustande
Union tritt heute Abend im Pokal gegen
Wolfsburg an die Highlights dieses
Spiels und alle anderen Achtelfinal zu
sehen bei uns bei heute.de und in der
heute App
rauschender Empfang für die deutschen
Hockey Weltmeister gestern Abend
reichlich Kölsch und fröhliche
Karnevalsmusik auf der WM Party Clubhaus
von Rot-Weiß Köln dem Heimatverein von
Kapitän Matz grambusch das deutsche Team
hatte am Sonntag in Indien die
Goldmedaille erkämpft der erste WM Titel
seit 17 Jahren doch kann man sich auch
mal richtig krachen lassen oder
und wir werfen noch einen Blick auf den
Mars wo der us-raum fortbehörde NASA
eine besonders niedliche Aufnahme
gelungen ist schauen Sie selbst von
einem lächelnden Weltraum Teddybär zwei
Krater bilden die Augen ein
eingebrochener Hügel die Schnauze der
Kreis drumherum könnte Vorstand zufolge
durch Lava oder Schlammablagerungen
standen sein
da wurde sein Zeichen geschickt
hier auf der Erde wartet uns morgen
einen wechselhafter nasser und windiger
Tag mehr zum Wetter gleich von Christa
Orben anni gallinek hat um 21:45 Uhr das
heute journal für Sie schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend es geht nass kalt und
stürmisch weiter denn tiefen Druck über
Skandinavien steht das Azoren hoch
gegenüber und dadurch entsteht eine
stramme nordwestströmung so gibt es
morgen außer im Südwesten verbreitet
Spitzenböen um 70 80 an der Küste oder
auch im Bergland und in schauen und
Gewittern bis 100 km/h schon heute Nacht
bleibt der Wind lebhaft letzte
restschauer gibt es im südlichen
Bergland im Norden verstärkt sich die
Schauertätigkeit mit einzelnen Gewittern
das ganze bei 0 bis 5 Grad nur im
Bergland ist das leicht frostig bis
minus zwei Grad hier dann auch
stellenweise glatt morgen erreichen die
Temperaturen drei Grad an den Alpen 9
Grad am Niederrhein und dazu ist es
ungemütlich immer wieder ziehen von
Nordwest nach südostschauer durch auch
mal mit graupeln und mit Gewittern am
meisten fällt nachmittags im Nordwesten
am wenigsten im Südwesten und dazu
gibt's diesen in Bönen schneiden kalten
Wind der in höheren Lagen auch für
Schneeverwehungen sorgen kann morgen
fällt zwar meist nicht viel aber im
nordwest-stau von Harz Erzgebirge
Thüringer und Bayerischen Wald ist es
schon etwas mehr und Schnee und
Schneeverwehungen sind auch im Rest der
Woche ein Thema in den Alpen bis
Freitagabend kann da nämlich zwischen 30
Zentimetern und einen Meter Neuschnee
zusammenkommen das ganze bei noch einmal
stürmischen Verhältnissen am Freitag
erst zum Wochenende wird das Wetter dann
so langsam ruhiger tschüss